donc c'est ici tous les deux pour le
premier long métrage de mathieu
delaporte qui s'appelle la jungle avec
vous deux guillaume gallienne anémone et
olivia magnani voit la sortie le 12
juillet alors le pitch c'est très simple
c'est comment survivre 7 jours et 7
nuits dans la jungle parisienne
c'est le pari que font deux fils à papa
c'est le début d'une aventure
initiatique et rédemptrice pour revenir
à villepin idole c'est la génération
cpe parce que on a beaucoup parlé des
jeunes des sites etc et on a raison d'en
parler mais il y avait des millions de
jeunes gens qui étaient pas qu'ils
vivaient pas la courneuve et zizou et
qui ne risque donc rien de sarkozy
directement mais qu'est né dans la rue
parce qu'ils en ont marre un petit peu
le travail le travail le travail le
travail c'est pas lui parler comme il
joue à un personnage qui se demande
pourquoi il faudrait travailler son père
a du fric et c'est bon mais et puis
c'est vrai que les jeunes gens
d'aujourd'hui vont de stage en stage et
et que a suscité pas très gentil par des
jeunes gens oui donc ils sont squatteurs
chez toi en fait et l année cette idée
absolument absurde 7 jours/7 nuits dans
paris avec 7 euros surtout il bloque
tous terre qui dit à tous les copains
qui sont présents à l'anniversaire que
je fais un anniversaire surprise sans
lui dire dans son appart qui est
beaucoup plus grand que le mien est là
tous les amis sont là comme il l'aura
fait beaucoup de crasse tous les copains
les deux là ils sont insupportables
tout le monde est bien content de les
[ __ ] dans la merde on leur prend les
clés les cartes bleues les téléphones
tous les épiciers les genres la banque
et où tout le monde est au courant il en
a même payé certains amis et là il se
retrouve vraiment donner un bras cassé
dans paris voilà dans la jungle
parisienne
dans sept jours et sept nuits alors
c'est un tournage assez assez
rock'n'roll parce que c'est vrai que
c'était dur tournant en vrai en fait
dans la vraie vie avec des vrais gens
quoi si tu veux ça a donné aussi la
vérité du film parce que comme il
fallait donner la réalité de ces deux
mecs dans la rue le fait de te connais
tu vas caméra à l'épaule et on a tourné
pendant place blanche en plein paris en
se cachant presque la caméra tu vois
qu'ils étaient cachés les gens ils
jouaient et faisait de la figure sans le
savoir on a fait sa gare du nord on a
tourné rue saint-denis le soir très tard
c'était c'était mais c'était très
encadré par le film repose beaucoup sur
vos batteries cas si en ce moment et
guillaume way au départ dans le
personnage qui est prêt à assouplir pour
une bonne vanne et puis ensuite on voit
effectivement là la fragilité derrière
ce personnage un peu fanfaron un peu
matamore espèce de rédemption à la fin
du film comme dans tous les bons films
si tu penses que c'est quelqu'un comme
souvent quand on est jeune comme lui il
a un peu de mal à agrandir à se cacher a
pas dire les mots il a jamais dit je
t'aime à la fille à qui il était et il
est même à son meilleur ami pourrait pas
lui dit
ne pas montrer les sentiments de la
carapace et c'est vrai que ce film tout
d'un coup ce mec qui préfèrent la vanne
pas ce qui se cache
voilà sa carapace son armure c'est la
vague mal arbres comme toi tu devrais
aller 7 jours cette veille de fête sa
vie et donc si tu veux c'est vrai il va
se retrouver dans la rue et là tout d'un
coup il va il va prendre conscience de
ce qui est important il va enfin pouvoir
dire les mots et c'est un way un vrai
parcours de rédemption qui est assez
étonnant pour une comédie parce que
c'est pas que drôle
ouais il ya des choses extrêmement drôle
de me tuer mais c'est un film aussi que
c'est touchant depuis sa part
logiquement ça aux jeunes quand ça va
leur parler s'appelle dit amusé et
intelligent